vamos a trabajar con algunos ejemplos
sobre multiplicación de fracciones pero
esta vez vamos a tomar en fracciones
negativas y positivas así que por
ejemplo si yo empiezo con menos 7 menos
7 que multiplica que multiplica a 3
entre 49 a 3 sobre 49 que me va a quedar
de esto bueno si te das cuenta aquí
tengo a un número entero multiplicado
por una fracción pero lo bueno es que
todos los números enteros los podemos
ver también como fracciones por lo tanto
podemos ver esto como menos 7 entre 1
menos 7 menos 7 entre 1 recuerda que
menos 7 entre 1 es lo mismo que menos 7
los estoy pasando este número entero a
fracción y esto que a su vez multiplican
que a su vez multiplica a 3 entre 49 a 3
entre 49 y ya tengo la multiplicación de
fracciones que se trabajar bastante bien
por cierto
nosotros sabemos cuántos esto esto es
exactamente lo mismo y voy a poner una
línea aquí aquí voy a poner un x o
espera que soporta
y un porta cam porque los voy a ocupar y
arriba me queda menos 7 ok menos 7 que
multiplica 3 que multiplica a 3 ok
todo esto dividido entre 1 y déjenme
cambiar a este color 1 que multiplica a
49 que multiplica a 49 ok y ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta en este vídeo
es que es lo que va a pasar justo acá
arriba cuando yo tengo la multiplicación
de menos 7 por 3 si nosotros nos tomamos
la multiplicación solamente en la parte
de arriba te vas a dar cuenta que esto
es lo mismo que 7 por 3 lo cual es 21 y
además hay que aumentarle este signo
negativo menos por más es menos menos
por más es menos y por lo tanto menos 7
por 3 es lo mismo que 21 y abajo abajo
me va a quedar la multiplicación de los
números positivos lo cual es muy fácil
de ver que es 49 49 ahora te cuento que
esta fracción de aquí es reducible
porque tiene tanto arriba como abajo
séptima es decir que voy a dividir la
parte de arriba entre 7 y la parte de
abajo también
dividido entre 7 de tal manera que voy a
hacer lo mismo tanto arriba como abajo
la fracción no se va a alterar y voy a
obtener una fracción irreducible menos
21 entre 7 esto es lo mismo que menos 3
ok y en la parte de abajo tengo 49 entre
7 lo cual es 7 es decir que la respuesta
de multiplicar menos 7 por 3 entre 49 es
lo mismo que menos 3 entre 7 o dicho de
otra manera es menos 3 séptimos estas
dos fracciones son exactamente iguales
ok ya encontramos la multiplicación de
un número negativo en un número entero
negativo por una fracción positiva que
pasa es y ahora me tomo el siguiente
ejemplo supongamos que tengo 5 novenos 5
novenos ok y ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar lo voy a multiplicar por
antequera cambiar de color por 3 entre
15 entre 15 bueno pues esta
multiplicación es muy fácil de hacer ya
las debemos realizar de una manera muy
rápida esto es lo mismo que es 5 por 3
por ahora voy a poner el 3 de este color
ok
todo esto dividido entre entre 9 por 15
99 por 15 por 15 ok ahora date cuenta
que si yo multiplico 5 por 3 esto tiene
que ver con el número 15 y 9 por 15
también tiene que ver con el número 15
así que si quiero simplificar de una
manera más rápida puedo dividir tanto
arriba como abajo entre 15 que es el
factor común y así vamos a encontrar una
fracción la cual sea irreducible en un
paso mucho más sencillo esto me va a
quedar 5 por 3 lo cual es 15 entre 15
bueno 15 entre 15 es lo mismo que uno
déjame cambiar de color
1 entre 9 por 15 entre 15 bueno pues eso
es 9 es decir que 5 novenos por 3 entre
15 es lo mismo que un noveno ok
positivo por positivo me da una fracción
positiva ahora qué te parece si nosotros
planteamos la siguiente situación
imagínate que me tomo menos 5 novenos
menos 5 novenos ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar lo voy
por menos 3 sobre 15 en este caso
tenemos las mismas dos fracciones que
tengo aquí arriba pero ambas son
negativas si ambas fueran positivas lo
que sí sabemos es que nuestro resultado
es un noveno así que vamos a suponer que
son positivas y nos da de resultado un
noveno ahora pensemos un poco en los
signos aquí tengo menos 5 entre 9 que
multiplica a menos 3 entre 15 es decir
un número negativo que multiplica a su
vez a un número negativo y bueno
nosotros sabemos que menos x menos o un
número negativo por un número negativo
me da un número positivo por lo tanto
aquí tengo más un noveno es decir un
noveno y esto quiere decir que es lo
mismo 5 novenos por 3 entre 15 que menos
5 novenos por menos 3 entre 15 si tengo
los dos positivos o los negativos llegó
a la misma respuesta a un noveno bueno
vamos a ver un último ejemplo pero vamos
a meterle muchos colores quiero dividir
a 3 entre a me voy a tomar ahora este
ok un último ejemplo ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar por menos 7 x menos 7 ok y
menos 7 lo voy a dividir entre 10 entre
10 y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo
por lo que acabamos de ver que 3 de 3
que multiplica que multiplica a menos 7
a esté menos 7 x al menos 7 y esto a su
vez dividido dividido entre 2 por 10 2
que multiplica que multiplica a 10 a 10
y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo y
por lo que hemos visto 3 por 7 es 21
pero aquí tengo el 7 negativo entonces
más x menos es menos menos 21 entre dos
números positivos multiplicándose 2 por
10 es 20 menos 21 entre 20 es mi
respuesta que es exactamente lo mismo
que menos 21 entre 20 ok y date cuenta
que 21 entre 20 no tienen factores el
común por lo tanto está
es una fracción irreducible